I have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine to david p here's
a voicemail i received from someone
who's just really distraught with Donald
Trump it Donald Trump supporters don't
care because there are no morals or
standards left in this country and the
millennium generation is even worse
because they have never been taught any
Donald Trump is a page so clearly very
very upset about Donald Trump and Trump
supporters and Millennials interestingly
a lot of people around this entire
election are really angry with
Millennials some calling them lazy some
people saying that progressive
Millennials are not understanding the
consequences of a trump presidency by
saying they're going to support either
Gary Johnson or Jill Stein a lot of ire
directed at Millennials during the
selection on the bonus show today I've
been nominated as treasurer what does
that mean where I'll explain on the
bonus show also some details from elon
musk about how the first Mars colonists
will live and four have died at a theme
park ride we will talk about all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
sign up on our website